marriage is a union between two people
who love each other who are committed to
each other who care for each other as
the phrase goes till death do us part
the opponents of equality for the LGBT
people want to define it strictly as man
and women the interesting thing is that
those unions end up in divorce the
divorce rate is half the marriages that
happen today break up in divorce that
lacks that essential element of a
marriage love that leads to commitment
to each other to people who are
committed to each other and so the
Supreme Court recognizing that equality
for two people who love each other who
made it be of the same sex is a major
step forward throughout history we have
been expanding equality to more and more
people when the nation was founded the
shining ideals were articulated by our
forefathers who kept other human beings
as slaves when they said all men are
created equal they meant that literally
women couldn't vote couldn't own
property didn't have rights over their
own children so equality granted to the
LGBT community now is in that American
tradition of expanding equality to more
and more people